Mm,
turkeys are a tough animal to cook
poetry in general,
and it's because there are two types of
muscle in Turkey,
there's the breast meat and the meat.
So a fast twitch muscle,
that's the breast meat.
Uh,
that's the muscle that's used for a
fight or flight.
The adrenaline,
the ones that the muscles at the Turkey
doesn't use very often during its
lifetime.
Then there's the slow twitch muscle,
which are the legs,
that dark meat.
I'm slow twitch muscle has a lot more
connective tissue in it,
so it needs to be cooked to a higher
temperature in order to make sure that
that connective tissue breaks down.
So typically when you're roasting a
Turkey,
you want the breast meat to come to
around 150 degrees or so,
and you want the leg meat to come to
around at least 165 to 175 degrees.
So.
So the issue is the same bird to
different temperatures.
How do you do that?
The way people typically cook a Turkey
is,
they'll put it in a roasting pan,
like in Iraq with a roasting pan,
was kind of high sides.
And that's actually the worst way you
can possibly cook a Turkey because that
roasting pan is heavy metal,
it has these high sides,
that kind of shield the bottom of the
bird,
which is where the legs are,
it shields it from the heat of the oven.
So your breast ends up overcooking far
before your legs are done.
Um,
and that's why so many people have dry
Turkey breast meat on thanksgiving,
the easiest way to deal with this
problem,
and there are all sorts of tricks.
I'm like flipping the bird upside down.
I'm turning it while it's in the oven,
icing down the breast.
They're separating it into parts.
I find the easiest way to do it is to a
butterfly to spatchcock the bird.
So you can,
you can either do that yourself with a
pair of poultry shears or you can ask
your butcher to do it for you.
Um,
and the idea is you cut out the backbone
of the bird and then you kind of splay
its legs out in this kind of
pornographic way,
um,
and uh,
and press down on the breasts so that
the whole Turkey lies flat with all of
the skin on top.
And what you end up with there is,
you'll find that the breast then becomes
sort of the biggest,
thickest part of the,
of,
of the,
uh,
the Turkey.
While the legs lie a little bit flatter,
the legs are exposed to more heat.
The breast gets a little bit less heat
that he goes into a little bit more
slowly because it's so thick.
And so naturally it ends up cooking
perfectly.
By the time your breast meat hits 150
degrees in the center,
your legs are like one 75.
All the meat comes out perfectly.
I'm using this method.
You can also cook a much higher heat and
cook much faster so you can,
you can cook a 12 pound Turkey in like
45 minutes to an hour using this,
which is about half the time it takes to
cook a traditional Turkey.
Um,
and then finally it also has all the,
all that skin,
all the skin gets exposed to the heat of
the oven so you get really nice crispy
brown skin.
So the only disadvantage to it is that,
um,
it ends up looking like a,
like a legs spread apart Turkey when you
bring it to the table.
But I always carve it in the,
in the kitchen in Britain and serve it
anyway.
And plus,
you know,
I would take good tasting Turkey over
great looking Turkey any day.